Charlie Manuel kind enough to call in on
this day here on the Rich Eisen show my
condolence to you Charlie yeah thank you
rich I guess there was a really tough
day for me of course and today you know
like I just I decided I wanted to talk
and I wanted to say something good about
Roy well then let's get to that who was
Roy Halladay as you can tell Roy
question what holiday was uh he was kind
of a white guy smiled a lot didn't have
a lot to say but he was a you know like
he had a he had a very good presence you
know like when he walked through the
clubhouse or actually walked on the
field you know when King was uh it was a
true Ultimo professional you know like
an anything he did like his workouts his
conditioning is his preparation you know
here to be a lot of competitive fire to
him you know like he determination you
know like he's a guy that came to the
big leagues and almost threw a no-hitter
had a no-hitter going at night and he
did he got broken up I think in his
first game he pitched and then pretty
soon he was back in sent back to done
gun eating in a ball and he worked his
way all the way back to the big leagues
and became a Hall of Fame pitcher really
I mean a star pitcher for quite a while
he was the guy that kind of replaced
Greg Maddux you know like as well as as
the horse in the Merkin International
League boys baseball goes well and and
you mentioned how he was in the u JS
system and how he sent him down a
Dunedin and he came up and he became a
scion pitcher and then then I guess he
decided he wanted to go somewhere else
he wanted to play somewhere else when
did you first hear that the Phillies
might be in on Roy Halladay in 2010
Charlie yeah rich you know I met him and
209 at the all-star game
my guy was manager and you liked it he
was the star opposing pitchers starting
opposing pitcher and to our first met
him and and I remember I looked at him
and I said you could you
the goodness filling uniforms you know
like and they kind of laughed and that
that winter you know like when we
started talking to him you know like
Gruber tomorrow called me and told me
says we got Roy a holiday for you man
and believe me I wasn't some kind of
excited I mean it was like I don't you
know like I couldn't believe it really
but but he came to us I think the reason
he came to us he liked our team he liked
the players that we had and also he came
out of win a World Series you know he
always made that very plain to me and
you know like we we came close but you
know like we couldn't get it done and
probably the game he pitched good st.
Louis you know like the one nothing game
where we lost and he pitched against
carpenter and I was one of his best
friends I grew up grew up in Toronto's
organization and it was a heck of a game
we lost 1 to nothing and that after the
game is pretty tough too for me to go up
and talk to him really you know like
because I know I knew how much he wanted
to win Charlie Manuel Phillies manager
for Roy Halladay when he was in
Philadelphia for those four years here
on the Rich Eisen show what was it like
trying to pull him from a game Charlie
you want to finish every game he started
he was uh he was very tough you know
like first of all you know like I didn't
really like to take him out you know
like because you know like I always
looked at him he's earned the right to
be there but most the time when I go to
the Mount you know like he would uh you
could tell I look at him and he'd be
staring at me and that makes you our
starter back real hard at him but you
know like that's another thing about him
Oh Ritchie was very professional even he
was he would never say nothing and to me
you're like in front of the players or
something like that he's a that's who he
was and but at the same time he used to
let me know I - the game was over he
could have finished it and things like
that and the biggest part of leaving
even though was you know like usually
when he got round about 7th or 8th
inning you know you'd have about about a
hundred and ten hundred fifteen twenty
pitches or something this time - that's
about the time to take him out of the
game and if you send him back out there
and let him finish you know like you get
in a spot where he has to finish your
game and all of a sudden he's up to her
thirty hundred forty pitches that's the
only problem and I had but at the same
time he understood it was uh he
understood everything about it he was
all for winning
it wasn't about ROI himself he never put
himself ahead of the team nothing like
that
he was a true professional and he was a
silent leader he was not a vocal leader
but at the same time like I said his
presence was off the charts so what was
it like Charlie on that day against the
Reds in the playoffs when he he did the
only what only darn Larson's been able
to do which is throw a no-hitter during
the playoffs what was it like that day
Charlie yeah I remember I watched him
and it was a it was a heck of a heck of
a game and it was you know like an all
of a sudden I looked up in his sixth
inning ahead and give up ahead and I
actually I was really getting you know
like I was so wound up in the game
meaning like I was watching I was
although I was watching the scoreboard I
didn't realize that he hadn't give up a
hit and I thought to myself well think
it's been listening he's got a good
chance of throwing a no-hitter here
today and he got three getting in the
last play of the game
Ruiz makes a heck of a play on the ball
check swing you know in between first in
the mound and hit a no-hitter and if you
notice when they play the clip in the
video of the game you know like he kind
of pauses he kind of stands over because
he acts like he don't know the game's
over with and then you know like I was
looking at it yesterday and I think it
kind of hit him ready to anotr and then
that perfect game earlier in the season
did you know that he had something
special because I mean he had he was the
first one of four wins in that April in
Major League Baseball that year it was
his first go-round in the National
League and he was just mowing people
down but I don't know if you saw
anything special on that perfect game
day that you knew that there was
something that was about to unfold in
Florida yeah sure did rich you know like
the Gator to game to different games
that the no-hitter to playoffs and the
no-hitter doing a record season in Miami
in Miami you're like it's about it was
about I don't know close to 100 degrees
but in 96 97
and he had a real good fastball and game
started and you know I can actually you
know like he usually uses all of his
pitches in the game and for about two
but about three innings you know like I
thought he was trying to just make sure
he established his fastball and you felt
good and he was strolling in the mid 90s
and upper 90s and he was just challenged
and they hit her and he's just moving
the ball up and down in and out went
throwing what uses off-speed stuff very
much
and he more or less was that was a big
power game for him and you know I can he
he just absolutely had had power stuff
at night in the game against in the
against Cincinnati in the playoffs yet
at all going you know like ietters yet
he had a breaking ball a curve ball
slider going good thinking fastball on
both sides of the plate but also his his
for sinking fastball had a lot of ride
to it up and you're like you and he
really had it going that night and
actually completely two different kind
of pitch games and but that's who he was
and that's kind of talent that he had
and then you know you can't spell
Halladay with an eye it was a team guy
and Charlie Manuel Phillies winning his
manager of all time and his manager and
Roy Halladay's manager here on the Rich
Eisen show from Philadelphia he gave
everybody a gift didn't he after that
perfect game he gave us he gave us all
of watch he gave he gave us a
major-league watch a big time question
her names on it date and everything the
game you know like absolutely amaze I
have never wore my watch I still got it
you know like in steel in the in the
little case that it comes in a beautiful
watch and that was screwed up but that
was quite a deal big deal and that's but
that's who he was
also also a rich you know like I used to
what some one of the things about it is
I've gotten really I got really close to
Roy as far as his two sons and I used to
work with him some time in a cage you
know like he'd always all Park real
early he'd bring his son sometimes and
Ryan I think we won
the oldest ones names Ryan do great and
he's bringing the ballpark and I go down
in Toby P to him and indicate some guys
and I got the Norman and you know like a
Roy not only at but he was a tremendous
father and his kids were very well
mannered kids and I can't say enough
about him really I guess for the final
statement then Charlie is the the
outpouring that's come from his
teammates and other pitchers with whom
he was never a teammate really has been
something else I don't know I'm sure
you're out um if you are monitoring what
people are saying on on Twitter and
Facebook and things of that nature why
do you think that is Charlie give us
somebody who doesn't know Roy a best
example as to why you think that is I
think it's I think Italia got along with
people and he any kind of carried
himself and he never and you know like
ting like I said it wasn't about Roy
Holladay you know like you it was about
us winning and and him doing the best
job he possibly could and also he was
such only on the Mount he was a big-time
competitor and he had like I said before
he had a he had a lot of determination
and a lot of pride to itself he was
determined he is going win and his
conditioning program kind of reminds me
to tell me that he thinks he's stronger
bigger and better shape and got better
stuff than anybody out there and you're
like and he's going to show that he's
the best guy want to feel that day did
you take out that water David does he
give you taking out that watch over the
last 24 hours to take a look at it no no
I haven't taken it out but you know what
actor hang up I might go do that go do
that Charlie and I really appreciate you
taking the time to share your thoughts
about Roy on a different day yeah thank
you rich you know yes thank you I look
at Roy's my brother my younger brother
you know like you know I was never a
father image for Roy I was a I look at
him as my younger brother you know you
know somebody that you love to be with
Charlie my condolences to you and your
family thank you thank you thanks for
calling Charlie manual for more Rich
Eisen show tuned to audience channel 213
Direct TV or download the Rich Eisen
show app